you get what you are educated for in my
country we are educated to glorify war
we are educated to believe that whenever
the United States invades another
country we're doing it for their good
there's no discussion of peace except
for to make fun of it I think if we want
sustainable peace which to me is based
on human security meeting the needs of
people not national security which is
about protecting the institution of the
state we have to stop accepting that war
is glorious
there is nothing heroic about war it is
blood and guts and people screaming
crying bleeding and dying war is always
hideous there may be individuals who act
heroically in war but war itself is a
failure of communication a failure of
States trying to work things out war is
a search for power and expansion of
power in my view we need to teach people
that that that is what war is about it
is not about bringing great or good to
other people